Republicans knock Ron DeSantis after
Florida Governor says help in Ukraine
is not a vital U.S interest several
high-profile Republicans including
Senator Marco Rubio Nikki Haley Liz
Cheney and Lindsey Graham are pushing
back against Florida Governor's Ron
DeSantis argument that helping Ukraine
fend off Russia's invading forces isn't
a vital International interest and a
questioner sent by Fox News host Tucker
Carlson descent has declared that
becoming further entangled
let's say a Jada Pinkett award yeah and
a territorial dispute between Ukraine
and Russia is not of vital interest to
the US and criticize the bite
Administration for Ukraine funding
Ukraine Rubio argued that Russia's end
goal is to overthrow the Ukrainian
government and rule the country and he
said the war should not be compared to
other conflicts or territorial disputes
settled with treaties or peace
agreements Haley accused DeSantis of
copying former president Donald Trump
stance on Ukraine and Cheney accused the
census of weakness and forgetting the
lessons of Ronald Reagan Graham tweeted
that allowing Russia to succeed in
conquering Ukraine invites aggression by
China and Taiwan thoughts I have a
hashtag called limbs for Liz where
people who lost their arms and legs and
military service can send the
Prosthetics to Liz Cheney's house
because there's not enough corpses and
dismembered people for her taste she
needs a second house she needs a second
condo this woman is pure evil and
frankly my understanding is that she was
the model for Miss Piggy if you put his
picture them side by side you can't see
the difference I don't I think what
DeSantis is doing is he's running for
the nomination and I don't think Nikki
Haley Liz Cheney and Lindsey Graham
between them see that's identical uh if
you have any am I wrong that's offensive
Michael why because it's Haram
[Laughter]
um I don't think between the three of
them they have any kind of clout with
the Republican base I think the
Republican base has become increasingly
radicalized and I think a year from now
when you're in New Hampshire and Iowa to
still be supporting pumping more money
to Ukraine is going to be extremely
unpopular with the Republican base
whether that's a good thing or not Adam
yeah I think what we're getting is a
little insight into Ron desantis's uh
mindset if if he were to run on a uh for
presidency which we all expect him to do
he's it could be as early as may I think
is when after the Florida
um
government situation kind of um
dissipates but he he's sort of queuing
to the base hey this is where I stand on
this and he's drawing a strong
delineation between what Biden stands
for which is obviously doubling down on
Ukraine quadrupling yeah all that he
sent every one of you know who was the
latest person that he sent over to
Ukraine it was uh
he sent Janet Yellen and then he sent um
Merrick Garland I believe to Ukraine
basically he's doubling down in Ukraine
he's basically saying this is the
difference between me and Joe Biden and
in the if that is who ends up running
against if he does get the nomination
he's sort of giving uh a heads up this
is where I stand and here's why this is
smart because the big Whispering
campaign coming out of trump and
maggoworld is that DeSantis is a closet
neocon when he was in Congress he's
basically another you know uh um uh
George W bush and there's a big concern
that he's a wolf in sheep's clothing and
that once he gets into office he's just
going to be a product of the military
industrial complex and just push for
Wars something that Trump uh from their
perspective did not do so this is a
great way for him to get ahead of that
criticism and be like I know you're
worried that I'm another Warhawk like
you get year after year with Republicans
but I'm really different and I'm not
going to be like what you're fearing I'm
going to be
I think I agree with that to a certain
extent it's really early and that's what
I every time I see these things here I
just bang around in my head it's just
like okay next it's really early you
know Nikki Haley has her motivations
clearly Lindsey Graham and Liz Cheney
you know they've got their motivations
and I think also
the classic technique you know of
whenever you have somebody emerging is
to start picking up Mitt Romney didn't
have the entire Republican party behind
him when he was emerging people were
picking at him I think you know it's
power brokering it's it's people like
Nikki Haley she's competing with him
she's a competitor just call it she's
competing for the Republican nomination
so she's a hard-nosed competitor so
we're not surprised about her yeah check
and everybody else has got their
um he's got their motivations and he is
the emerging front runner and I think a
lot of people are trying to shift the
power where they want it to be you know
you know one of the things that I think
you is a is a sign of a guy that's got
the chances of winning is you have to
take a hard position yeah and get a ton
of backlash and still stand firm and
then the market says wow good for him
and then the argument creates momentum
kind of like what you're doing right so
think about like your argument of no let
me tell you
okay well maybe he's got a point now you
got to have your Tipping Point for that
argument to really go but I think I
think the scientist has to take this
position
um I think it favors him not whether
people right like it or not it is what
it is there's a lot of people right now
that are kind of sitting there that were
all pro Ukraine Let's help these guys
out change the flag colors on my Twitter
profile now it's like I don't know about
all this money that we're spending and
we're experienced in America so I think
it could help them out position wise I'm
not sure the level of credibility with
the other guys you you don't want to be
the group of 18 people that agree
disagree with the one guy right because
you're in a market differentiate like
why why am I buying RC Cola because I'm
cheaper there's got to be something
better though okay there's gotta be
something I'm a Dr Pepper guy there's
gotta be something that distinguishes me
from the other from the from the other
brands uh um and I think it's um I think
for the this for the most this is the
most extreme Time In Our Lifetime where
there is a disconnect between a party
and its base specifically between the
Republic looking party they're probably
gonna base I don't think we've ever seen
anything like it the Animus that the
Republican base has towards the
Republican Party can I say one more
thing about this uh do that and then I
want to go to this next just real quick
because they keep using the word of
national interest this is not uh
DeSantis says specifically this helping
Ukraine does not fend off
um evading forces isn't of national
interest one could argue yes this is not
of national interest but this is of our
International interests right so
obviously NATO is an International
Alliance that that is there to protect
typically Europe
against Russia's Invasion and one could
argue that all right if we allow this to
happen what's next what's the slippery
slope that happens with Poland or
Finland and we've seen that Finland and
Norway or whoever it is just recently
been introduced to Nato
um and then then you hear you have here
is uh Lindsey Graham even tweeting that
allowing Russia to succeed in conquering
Ukraine speaking of slippery slope now
invites China to invade Taiwan so where
does it end if U.S doesn't draw the line
on these types of situations then where
does it end because at certain point
then China is going to even more so
beyond Russia's side so if you want to
play brinksmanship it's not going to be
like the good guys always win if you're
assuming that we're the good guys as we
just demonstrate in Afghanistan
yeah why not I completely understand on
that but so but at the end of the day
one can say that this is what I said a
couple uh weeks ago I think this is a
vital U.S interest to stand Pat on what
we believe in democracy you can't just
invade countries I think that's
something that we should whether it's
soft power Howard power throwing money
on it that we should stand behind are
you willing Central this is my no not
not whatsoever the one that you could
always argue is how much money how much
money can we be spending is it where do
we draw the line on that right now we're
at a hundred billion dollars are we
willing to commit another 100 billion
dollars how about a trillion dollars we
spent what a trillion dollars in
Afghanistan if not more we spent four
trillion [__] dollars in Iraq so one
could argue hey the money just doesn't
at make sense whatsoever but standing
firm on on what we believe in I think is
there's no amount of money that we can
put behind that would you regard it as
somehow wrong if Putin started targeting
American uh sources resources
like if you started bombing American
bases
well now he's in just somewhere would
you regard that as somehow illegitimate
what do you mean by illegitimate meaning
like okay it's not an act of War then
yes but the point being like would you
be surprised at a certain point If
You're Gonna Keep funding his opponent
we start becoming parties to this war
ourselves no question about it yeah yeah
so you're playing a very dangerous game
where you can it's easy to be like we're
the good guys before democracy you're
not going to do it but we're not going
to send troops at a certain point he's
like [__] you yeah that's going to be
very that's something I'm terrified I
totally understand and that's a great
argument but the other the other end of
the of the spectrum is all right do we
just allow Putin to do whatever he wants
with no consequences if we don't step up
we're America I mean like the world goes
as America sort of goes like if we don't
step up if we don't lead who leads that
China Russia Iran like we need to stand
for something here I I hear what you're
saying but at a certain point our the
problem the Thatcher very famously said
the problem with socialism is eventually
run out of other people's money we have
limited resources and this idea that we
can fund Wars everywhere across the
world in perpetuity wherever so-called
democracy is threatened I think flies
that is the utopian perspective and at a
certain point we have to be like all
right this sucks we're like North Korea
is a great example you know if I had my
druthers and talk about utopian if I had
a magic wand I would Liberate the North
Korean people we can't do that because
the military and and so on and many
other uh China's has their backing so
yes I like the idea of protecting
liberalism in whatever form it takes
throughout the world but at a certain
point we're making ourselves the targets
and we're going to have other 911s yeah
I agree and that's essentially my point
is that what amount of money are we
willing to commit to this I don't I
think
speeches soft power saying what we
believe in that doesn't cost anything
and I think that's what we should be
doing I think it's fully in our right to
argue hey this is where else could this
money be used I I think that we need to
stand for what we believe in and not
invading Sovereign Nations I think is
sort of tantamount but what does
Stanford what we believe and mean that
can mean anything up to boots on the
ground
well if I'm not sending troops am I
really standing for what I believe in if
I'm not you know putting lives in risk
or I'm just talking out of my ass at
that point right
you're saying that you have to send
troops or send if I really want to stand
for what I believe in Then I then
there's no price too high the heavens
fall are you going to to the speech he
gave about the Americans uh will need to
send their sons and daughters no I'm
just going to his point that like look
listen if there's if we have to stand up
for what we let's make Putin it makes it
even easier if it's like Putin's like a
Hitler figure like like really just pure
evil and and the ukrainians
like labeling that are we are are you
comfortable always allocating no matter
how many resources we have to always
fighting dictators and at certain point
the answer is we can't we at a certain
point we're gonna run out of military
we're gonna run a Weaponry we're gonna
have people's patience too and that's
the big problem so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you
foreign